I know you're excited to run the app and
I'm going to show you how to do it
without a physical device because we'll
be using the emulator but first we need
to install one more component from the
Android SDK manager click on this button
to open up the Android SDK manager
scroll to the bottom of the list to find
hexam it stands for hardware accelerated
execution manager and it will speed up
our emulator so go ahead and deselect
the other packages and just install this
one accept the license and then continue
we have to do one more step after this
to install haxon i'll show you the
remaining steps on a Mac but for the
other platforms you can check the link
below
first find android studio under the
Applications folder and then hit show
package contents then in the SDK folder
there'll be an extras folder containing
an Intel folder with the hexam folder
then we click on the dmg file open it up
and then continue step through this
installer and the default values are
fine once the installation is complete
you can close all the windows